[Música]
Bienvenidos a enlace andino en esta
edición desde Lima Perú el tema de hoy
está enfocado en la corrupción que ha
llevado a que seis expresidentes sean
investigados por sobornos lavado de
activos entre otros sin embargo en Perú
la corruptela no solo se produce en las
altas esferas del poder también llega a
diferentes instituciones estatales
[Música]
la procuraduría anticorrupción ha
reportado más de 3.000 casos Durante los
primeros tres meses de este año mientras
que en todo el país se contabilizan más
de 52.000 por parte de funcionarios y
según datos de la contraloría general
durante el 2022 Perú perdió más de 6.500
millones de dólares por corrupción de
autoridades
Alejandro Toledo Pedro Castillo Martín
vizcarra Pedro Pablo kuczynski y ollanta
humala están siendo investigados y
recibirán sentencia dentro de unos meses
Alberto fujimori cumple una condena de
25 años por violación de derechos
humanos y corrupción mientras que al
extraditado Alejandro Toledo la justicia
iniciará este año un juicio y podría
pasar los próximos 35 años en prisión
acusado de colusión y lavado de activos
por millonarios sobornos que habría
recibido de la constructora brasileña
odebrecht los expertos afirman que los
ex mandatarios han causado un grave daño
moral a la nación es un proceso
tristemente generalizado y los
presidentes son el epítome de esta
grotesca manifestación cultural Esto
está enraizado Lamentablemente en los
antivalores no los antivalores son
principios interiorizados por una
cultura
de formas correctas de comportarse y
Cuál es esta forma correcta
ayudarse entre amigos y la familia más
allá de lo correcto las autoridades
disponen un promedio de 150 a 200
carpetas de investigación donde los
delitos más comunes son apropiación del
dinero del Estado cobro de sobornos por
parte de funcionarios públicos
manipulación de contratos negociación
incompatible aprovechamiento indebido
del cargo entre otros la procuraduría
anticorrupción revela que las
instituciones que acogen la mayor
cantidad de actos de corrupción son las
municipalidades seguidas de los
gobiernos regionales y los ministerios
el Ministerio de vivienda y el de
transporte son los más denunciados el
año pasado la procuraduría
anticorrupción cerró en
54.500 procesos
la media de ingresos de casos a nivel
nacional Es aproximadamente mil casos
esto qué quiere decir en enero
ingresaron 1326 casos en febrero 1222 en
marzo 1171 hoy Cuando hacemos el cierre
de la carga que maneja la procuraduría
tenemos
52.224 casos la corrupción al ser
sombría y oculta no deja recibos y por
tanto no se pueden cuantificar los
sobornos pero la contraloría general del
país mediante un complejo esquema de
auditorías y protocolos descubrió el
perjuicio económico generado Por La Mala
conducta funcional en el aparato Estatal
el año 2022 se estiman en más de 6,500
millones de dólares que se han perdido
por corrupción e inconducta funcional
esto equivale a que de cada 100 dólares
que en el estado se gastan para los
temas de las inversiones para obras para
la consecución de los bienes y servicios
públicos etcétera de cada cien dólares
se pierden Trece punto cuatro casi Trece
dólares de cada 100 dólares en un
reciente sondeo de opinión de la empresa
ipsos el 57% de los encuestados
considera que la corrupción es el
principal problema que afecta al Perú al
caminar por las calles este país es muy
difícil encontrar gente que no haya sido
perjudicada por este delito es el caso
de René inciso un comerciante de 50 años
quien afirma que en diferentes etapas de
su vida los funcionarios públicos le han
exigido dinero La última vez ocurrió
Hace unos días para evitar una multa de
500 a 600 dólares fue un policía que me
extorsionó a mí No si bien es cierto que
yo estaba en falta con el vehículo que
estaba haciendo un cambio de placas y no
debía circular como él me dijo No pero
lo primero que me pides dinero o sea
para para dejarme pasar Dame tanto o si
no te vas al depósito no Y a ver
depósito dos mil 2500 soles que hice En
ese momento pues darle lo que tenía O
sea no me quedaba otras ese hecho mal
también no hecho mal pero la policía
mayormente trabaja así algunos críticos
de la sociedad peruana afirman que es
condescendiente con los corruptos
mientras que otros señalan que los
peruanos rozan los límites de la doble
moral hay un elemento más complicado
porque hasta acá llegamos la
condescendencia y la proclividad de ser
corruptos solapa corrupto discreto sino
que existe el valor de la viveza criolla
Es decir de sacar provecho creativamente
de la oportunidad transgrediendo la
norma Entonces es el mundo al revés no
solamente somos permisivos con la
corrupción con los amigos y la familia
sino que celebramos cuando es hecha de
manera creativa los expertos aseguran
que la corrupción seguirá creciendo en
Perú A menos que haya alguien con la
estrategia y determinación de eliminar
de raíz el problema Gracias por
acompañarnos en esta edición de enlace
andino desde Lima Perú sigan disfrutando
de la programación de Francia 24 en
español y hasta pronto
[Música]